Course plot; October 17th 1975.
Time travel. Cool.
- The future of the world is in your hands.
- I like killing people.
- My hair, it's so thick!
- Let's go spark a doobie.
I'm a Time Master. Making discrete alterations to the timeline is what I do.
Would you people please stop hitting me?
Hey YouTubers, it's Charlie.
So new rolling papers Legends of Tomorrow trailer. Who knew Martin Stein liked to blaze so much?
Now as hilarious as it is to think about the White Canary going to blaze up with young Martin Stein in the 70's
you notice that they're at Ivy University, which is a huge location in the Firestorm and the Atom comics.
Now obviously the Ray Palmer's a more contemporary version on the show; he's not really associated with Ivy University quite as much as he is in the comics
but he was actually one of Ronnie Raymond's professors.
Now here, like because they have Victor Garber they just tied him to Ivy University more than they have the Atom.
The Atom inside this like Arrow/Flash universe is a little bit closer to the Blue Beetle character, to the Ted Kord character.
That's who he was originally intended to be actually.
But as much as they have all these really awesome super-powered characters in the show, they're gonna do these big special effects, Victor Garber is like their secret weapon.
Normally you'd think it'd be harder for genre shows like this, especially shows on smaller networks to land actors that're that accomplished.
Like I was really surprised when Tom Cavanagh signed on to The Flash.
Now obviously The Flash turned into this amazing show so now it's not a surprise at all.
But part of the reason they were able to get Victor Garber is because he'd previously worked on a bunch of Greg Berlanti shows,
same thing with Tom Cavanagh; they'd all worked together previously. Like Marc Guggenheim, like all the producers, all the people behind the scenes,
and the people on camera had worked together on previous shows.
So any time they change like little titbits about Martin Stein from the comics, I totally don't mind, because some of those actors are so amazing.
Victor Garber's scenes with Cisco are some of the best in The Flash. Martin Stein was the character that they gave the Multiverse explainer to at the beginning of The Flash season this year.
"Multiple versions of our Earth, some with things that are a little bit different, some with things that are wildly different."
Fun fact: there was actually a scene from the pilot that they cut out and then used much later; the first time we saw Martin Stein on the train.
That was a scene that they shot for the pilot but then removed just because they felt it worked better in a different episode.
Originally after the two-part episode of Arrow that introduced the Barry Allen character, the story was: is that he took the train home,
so you can kinda see early on that The Flash was always planning to do the Firestorm character, and they had cast Victor Garber really early on.
Really the biggest change that I can think of to Legends of Tomorrow in terms of the cast is the Hawkman character.
Originally they didn't know if they were gonna do Carter Hall. Not that it was last minute or anything, I mean they decided pretty early on they wanted it to be a team-up show,
like they decided they wanted Hawkman, then it became Legends of Tomorrow. It was still like a Hawkgirl Hawkman show before it was a team-up show.
Speaking of which, part of the reason why they made it a team-up show is because they wanted to go even bigger than The Flash.
I know a lot of people have been wondering like what happens if Arrow goes off the air after five seasons?
Because to my knowledge, the actors have not been signed passed season 5, the actors on Arrow.
Really that could change at any time, and Marc Guggenheim, the show runner, said the show will continue as long as Stephen Amell wants to continue making it,
which just means that they'll just keep going until they don't wanna do it any more.
But the question then becomes what would be like the next biggest thing they could do after Legends of Tomorrow?
Like if the CW wanted another superhero show to fill the hole left by Arrow's absence.
Before they made the big Suicide Squad movie announcement, I would've said a Suicide Squad show would've been something that they could totally pull off.
But because they're turning it into a big movie franchise, they had to kinda kill off the Deadshot character on the TV show, not gonna do a whole lot of Suicide Squad episodes.
But they could totally do a Rogues TV show or a Firestorm TV show.
I think it'd be a little bit easier for them to do a Rogues show just because they could rotate the cast a little bit more,
and it's really expensive to do Firestorm visual effects all the time, that's why you haven't seen Firestorm quite as much.
So that's actually a good question for you guys, let me know in the comments: in a couple years, when it gets time to figure out whether or not they're gonna keep doing Arrow,
or they're gonna cancel it, which characters that they've already established do you want them to create a new spin-off for, to fill that hole, so they still have their three shows on the air?
For my money they spent the most amount of time developing Rogue characters, it just makes sense that they would do a Rogue team-up show.
Speaking of big team-ups, though, I'm gonna do like a short video for it on Facebook, but if you guys didn't see MTV just premiered Shannara Chronicles,
starring Manu Bennett, who was Deathstroke and Azog from The Hobbit movies, so you should definitely check that out.
It's on MTV, I think they'll play it in their web player if you missed it on air.
But I've also got some new Star Wars that I'm gonna do for tomorrow, so be sure to subscribe to get everything.
And congratulations to this week's giveaway winner. Progenitor, please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact info.
I've already started a new round this week, all you have to do to enter that is be a subscriber and leave a comment on this video, it's real simple.
Just in case you guys haven't seen it I posted a video earlier today all about Daredevil season 2 dropping on the exact same day that Batman v Superman is coming
so it'll be like Marvel vs DC. You can click here to learn all about that. Big battle royale.
And you can click here to learn all about Deathstorm coming to The Flash season 2.
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody, let's high five, I'll see you guys tonight.